Hey, how it's going bros, my name is PEWDIEPIE!
Today, I'm gonna bake with..
Someone very special...
My uh, GF:
Marzia! Clap it up, everybody! It's Marzia!
[Fake Marzia enters]
CIAO!
Pewds: Ciao! C-Ciao Marzia are you-
Marzia: CIAO
Marzia: Come va? (How's it going?)
Pewds: Finally, we haven't cooked in so long....
Marzia: I know!
Normally we do it on my channel
Pewds: We always do it on your channel but today...
Special day,
*april 1st a.k.a. april fools is a very special day*
cooking on my channel, with Marzia
And may I say, you look, very beautiful today...
Pewds: *awkwardly* No...
*both laugh*
M: Thank you
P: Excellent!
M: I put-
M: -extra effort in because I knew that I would be on the channel with the "bRoS"
"MaRzIa", thank you for caring about the bRos
*awkward silence*
M: kee
s me
*Brad breaks character and laughs*
P: We'll do it!... we'll do it after the video!!
When we're done making....
THE TRANSFORMERS CUPCAKES!!!!
M: Transformers was my favorite...
P: Nonono, it's my... it's my..
M: ...in Italia!
P: It's my favorite!
M: When I was a child I used to watch it in Italia!
P: ..no.
P: It's my-!
M: brO!
P: It's...
M: I usED TO WATCH IT IN ITALIA YOU NEED TO--
P: okay, Okay OKAY
P: But it's my favorite, it's my own...
M: MY CHILDHOOD WAS...
...important too!
P: *sniffle laugh*
P: Okay...
M: WHY AM I AMERICAN?? (???)
P: I don't know...
*Brad breaks character again and laughs*
P: I have a lot of questions about this...
Brad: *laughs*
P: So why don't you instruct us how you cook
'Cause you're Marzia and you always make such delicious cake for me!
M: Okay
well
When you making transformer (what does that even mean?)
P: yeah..?
M: You wanna (to?) make it nice and fresh...
...for your...
...lover...
P: Whaddo you mean? ...
M: ...So that he could eat it off of your body... (what)
P: oooookay...
M: ...At the end of the video!
P: At the end we're gonna do that!!! okay!!!
*laughing*
It's pre-mixed so we don' even have to do anything (Marzia: Gravel, with some gravel)
from the ground
some dirt!!
okay!
m'kay
ITALIA!
*perfect Italian*
Y'know I love when you speak Italian Marzia
All you need is an egg!!!
An egg??
I have very fertile eggs!
*silence*
Go away Marzia!! (marzia laughing in the background)
You're not allowed to see this!
*clears voice*
Why don't we crack it together?
as a symbol
of our child (??)
[mumbling] That we'll never have
*clank*
gREAT JOB!!!
*shows off how not cracked this egg is*
I don't think this is the right thing to crack it on..
just...
There you go!
*tension*
Oh MY gOD
*laughing*
I'm so scared!!
*breaks*
AAAAAAAYYYYYYYY!!!!!!
That's like.... SUPER EFFECTIVE!
OH MAY GAWD!!
here
I don't know what to do with this, I don't live here...
*laughing*
So do we put this now??
I guess so... I...
wait... this one's
they say:
this is the biscuit mix
and this is the icing
oh.
But they look identical!
Let's do both, yeah...
see what happens...
I'll add the icing.
So!!!
Once you have everything
Butter! (Felix: butter.)
In italia we call it el butter-ia~
el what????
el butter-ia
Sorry, what?
el... say after me...
el!!
el
butt
eria!!!!
el but...
el butter-ia...
you have to go pretty HIGH!!!!
okay...
EL BUTTER-IA!!!!!!!!!
EL BUTTER-IA!!
is that....
no??? (marzia: neh)
not good enough..? (marzia: eh)
alright.... fine.
How much butter should we put?
ALL OF IT!!!!!
all of it?? k...
THIS IS ITALIA!!!!
this is how we...
doesn't...
that seem a little much??
Should we have melted it first???
I don't know...
Marzia, you are good at cooking!
I don't understand....
You act so different today!
It's almost like you're another person!!
THIS IS REALLY HURTFUL AND HARMFUL TO THE RELATIONSHIP (+Felix trying to apologize)
TO SAY THAT ARE YOU DREAMING OF OTHER PEOPLE IN YOUR RELATIONSHIP??? (Felix still trying to apologize
YOU DONT CARE ABOUT THIS RELATIONSHIP YOU DONT LOVE ME ANYMORE DO YOU WANT TO BE WITH SOMEONE ELSE [Felix still apologizing]
WELL YOU CAN BE WITH SOMEONE ELSE *MUMBLING*
Just for the video!!
Scissors is really....
This is a really good life hack!
Yeah! Sh-show the audience!
Wait you're scooping out of...
I have been working on my London accent!
So I can fit in here in England!
Really? Can  I hear it?
"OOOyY!"
"YOU SLAG!!!"
"STIR IT!!!!"
What do you think????
I'm so turned on right now...
Pretty sexy right??
What you're gonna do is...
use plain fine flour- *horrible screeching*
INTENSE MIXING
*sexy music*
*laughing*
eeeww
ew...
this is butter! this is pure butter!
(It tastes gre-)
OH YOU GOT SOMETHING ON YOUR NOSE!
OH REALLY??
Oh it's so romantic!
Will you get it off my nose?
yes of course...
*sexy music, again*
(brad breaks character) That's your spit!
It's a little loose!
Just a little loose!
LIKE YO MOM!
you know you're not supposed to talk about my mother like that....
[silence]
*burps* -_-
How much?
all of it
*laughing*
This is enough!
That's enough!
The perfect cookie shape!
m'kay..
You see?
Okay, a cowboy hat
It looks like a cowboy hat!!
And now we... put it in the oven!
Yes.
For fifteen minutes!
Fifteen minutes!
What should we do in... for fifteen minutes?
*awkward silence* *slowly shows boobs*
*laughing and crying at the same time* *Felix being shoved closer to them boobs*
*sexy music.... yet again*
UHHHHHH
That was AMAZING -_-
WAS IT THE BEST SEX YOU'VE EVER HAD???
Every time with you is the best.
OH MY GOOOOD
IT'S SOO NICEE
It looks like a real cookie!
It looks like a cowboy hat!
It actually kinda does...
Why don't you have a camera man today? Normally you have that slave boy..
Yeah but..
You forced him to do things for no pay with...
I don't like him anymore!
...why?
he's just not attractive..
I think he's pretty hot! owo
Are we actually eating it??
I don't know...
I don't know either... (there's no texture!)
It's...
It's a little stuck.. it's...
just a lil' stuck...
Oh wow, it comes off just like a real cookie!
wooww, if you break it like it's a spaghetti!! (???)
*laughing*
That how you get it off in Italia!!!
sebe b-be samicia (wtf)
mmmmm.....
mMMMMM
That is goooooooooooood!
wow!
Spaghetti cookie!!
With Marzia!! (Spaghetti cookie..!)
You're so good at this!
Thank you
Hey! Why don't we...
*sexy music!! again!!*
It's really strange, cause I have never tasted anything that tastes like this
In... how old am I?
in my 24 years of life!
Wait, who are you talking to?
Felix!
Who are you talking to?
But.... I thought...
you were..
How did you???
How did this happen?
Who am I????
HUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUH
I already touched it and I don't wanna....
SQUEEZE IT
WITH YOUR MOUUUUTH
*laughing*
*brad laughs* felix: hhhhh